15 Grammys later and you finally give us
a Christmas album what took you so long
I'm mad you're right I have beef with
you no you are actually factually right
I also can't believe that it's been the
whole time that I've never done a
holiday album but it's time now yes when
I think of you I think of timeless music
I think of classic so this just seems so
right what made you decide this was the
time to do it you know it just felt it
felt like a good time it felt like there
was some some space to create it yeah it
felt like we had a good idea about what
I wanted to do how I wanted to do it and
I was on tour and I was able to kind of
snatch some days
um so it was fun it was fun it felt good
even though it was July and I was like
this is a little strange it actually
felt satisfying I would leave the studio
be like it just feels strangely good
yeah so I think that's kind of what
happens with these songs you know
they're so great and and they they their
class six and they make you have
memories it's just it's so much attached
to it that it feels really good and then
I was able to write some new ones as
well so that it gave some different
Vibes yeah how do you tap in to your
childhood to figure out what Classics to
sing
yeah I just went straight for my
favorites I was like what is my what are
the ones that make me feel like oh yeah
and I remember going straight to
Christmas Time Is Here that's one of my
like I don't know it just feels good
when I hear it I feel warm I remember
going straight to Santa Baby because
Earth the kids version is just too cute
she's just so cute yeah and and then I
remember kind of you know just picking
certain ones I actually love the version
of favorite things on Santa Baby because
it it takes just that Melody of favorite
things but then it has like a whole
other vibe to it so I it was just it was
kind of like that and I just danced with
it and played it and see if it would
work and it's just all fit together what
was your favorite childhood Christmas
memory because we're both only children
okay so we gotta go all the presents
I got all the presents I know you did
um I feel like I remember I have a
picture of it too I feel like I remember
when I got my first pair of roller
skates oh it was a big deal it was like
a moment I remember putting them on in
the house you know we lived in a one
bedroom apartment we had the little tree
in the corner and I put them on in the
house and I have the picture of it and I
was super excited so that was that was a
good one that was a good one let's talk
about the first single
it is an original yes how do you even
get these lyrics together because like
we're Christmas spirit in July on tour
right let's talk about making it single
December back to June is so good I love
this song so much
um it has almost like a throwback micro
Vibe you almost feel like it's a Jackson
5 sample but it's actually not uh the
producer his name is Tommy he kind of
created that that that that's that tone
with that voice and it just felt so good
I was like this is the Zone it's like
you don't know my name in Christmas
that's how I felt like the song kind of
gave me that energy so I loved it wrote
it with Taylor Parks as well she's
amazing and I just loved how it all came
together and we were able to really have
this original Vibe I wrote a couple of
other original ones too which were a
little bit more like sentimental but
this one just felt like it had the
festivity the energy yeah and we were
able to make it happen so we are in New
York with Alicia Keys yeah think of
Alicia Keys I think of New York when I
think in New York I think Alicia Keys
simultaneously eat period okay what is
your favorite thing about New York my
favorite thing about New York is is
everything honestly I love that you can
walk everywhere I love that you can you
know I love that you get such a sense of
so many different kinds of people I love
that you feel the energy to hustle the
bustle I love the train I love the fact
that you can go down one block and you
have like totally different experiences
I think you can go to different
neighborhoods and feel different Vibes
and different energies it's just
electric there's no place like it yeah
you have been a staple in this industry
since you were young you've been out
here for a minute a sec okay two or
three seconds
what type of advice would you give to
your younger self like Fallen Alicia
what would you say to her I would tell
it not to be so nice
oh
good I would tell her that she has to
understand her worth and her value and
she has to demand that that that holds a
level of of respect that she has to
demand nobody's going to give it to her
in fact they're going to try to make her
think that she doesn't deserve it that
they're doing everything for her but
really I would and I would say don't
don't give in so easy don't compromise
too much and don't be too nice yeah
that's what I would tell her
being in the game for so long you've
avoided a lot of the things that a lot
of celebrities go through
I've never seen you like I've seen no
Paparazzi pictures of you drunk or acted
a mess well because I know how to handle
my business oh
she's like breeze through this like how
how do you manage Fame in that way
because you've done it really well thank
you actually that actually means a lot
to me I care about that and I think that
I think that's really cool because the I
think you can just as a human being you
can just kind of lose it and you you can
get really off balance and you can you
know be around people that don't really
they're not really out for you and and
so um but for me my mama I have to give
credit to my mama she raised me only
only child like you and single mother
and she was really she was real like I
feel like seeing her struggle to put it
all together and make it all happen gave
me a certain respect for like just being
aware I was always terrified of like
losing everything always that was kind
of my almost a little bit of what
motivated me in a lot of ways which was
not always from the best headspace but I
think she gave me that sense and she
would always be like you know you're not
to this and you need to be humble and
you need to get yourself and she would
always kind of just check me she knew
how to
and I think it was good it was good in
the sense of like just understanding
what's real and what's not and being
able to navigate that in a decent way
but I don't know it's just God it's just
I'm just grateful because
anything happened yeah you know you've
had people like Prince call you and give
you advice I know give advice about
sound at a show that's true and I know
that you are a mentor for a lot of
younger artists one name in particular
who's our Canadian boy Shawn Mendes oh I
love done I know what is that like for
you to basically just Mentor younger
artists and just give them advice
because I know you're someone that
people would definitely want to get
advice from I just love to talk to
people and I'm definitely a I'm
definitely a great year I think that
it's a safe place to speak you know you
can not feel like you it's hard because
you don't know who to talk to you know
who I remember feeling like that too I
shoot I feel like that now you know who
who do you who do you talk to who do you
trust when you're going through
something tricky or you don't know how
to navigate something who's the person
that would actually understand and help
you figure out what whatever a next step
is or have a similar story or just be
like it happened to me whatever the case
you know
um and so I love it I love it and I'm
and I'm definitely I'm a genuine person
so I'm not a phony so that's another
thing we could tell
we can tell girl these phonies you'd be
like God
yes where
so I love it I love it so big love to
Sean yeah big love the show that's right
he's Canadian Canada count them up okay
I gotta tell y'all what they are you
know
um giving advice to younger artists you
know what type of advice would you give
to them when they are maybe struggling
with touring maybe dealing with anxiety
maybe managing Fame like there's a lot
that comes with getting into this game
at a young age so what type of advice
would you give to them I try to talk I I
feel like one of the things has helped
me a lot is you know really realizing
that I have to have a relationship with
myself I think a lot of times you get so
used to listening to everybody else
especially if you come into a space
quite young you know everybody's telling
you what to do but this is going to work
and this is why it's going to work and
you need to do this and if you don't do
that this person's not going to do that
and you get like confused about your
obligations
for everything and so I think that
having a relationship with yourself
allows you to Define what what works for
you and what do you want how do you want
it to go how do you want to feel and so
um you know just even talking about
meditation or talking about just Journal
writing or time time away or maybe like
I was talking to my friend I mean it's
for anybody but I was talking to my
friend about even just like putting our
phones down I mean that's how much you
get so attached to like the thing and
then you you you're like at dinner and
you're texting you're like what the hell
I'm not even eating I'm not even talking
to anyone I can't stand it's like and
you can see how it can happen
um but anyway so I I I feel like that's
a lot of some some of what we might talk
about and and that helps everything that
helps the anxiety that helps the stress
of touring that helps the navigating of
Fame it helps it all so yeah I love that
yeah I know you worked with Whitney on
her final album
I know
ah she's so incredible oh my gosh so
incredible yes her prince I mean there's
been a lot of people man yeah so
grateful so incredible but I know you
worked on her final album will you be
watching the biopic I just got the whole
alert about the whole biopic I was like
wait what yeah so when is it happening
it's coming out soon is it like not
tonight not tonight not tomorrow night
not tomorrow night maybe this weekend we
gotta ask somebody does anybody know
does anyone know
just in time just in time of course I'm
watching you know I think sometimes I
get
I love her and you just want people to
honor people the way that they actually
are you know what I mean and I'm sure
that that's what they did so I'm excited
to watch it yeah
you want to biopic about you one day
yeah
you better let someone know now okay you
know what yes yeah yes obviously with it
done in a beautiful way and with it like
really to be creative and to be able to
go a little deeper with all the things I
think it would be kind of cool who do
you think would do a great job playing
you
the first person that comes to my head
is her
oh
yes just because you know we we both
play and you know there's some similar
background Vibes there and we I think
she under we understand each other a lot
you know she's a she's a dear friend to
me and I think that she's unbelievably
incredible so
um something like that might might work
I gotta think of some other folks though
too yeah is there anyone that looks like
you I'm trying to think who looks like
you too
anyone that comes to mind
you we could be sisters hey adopt me all
right adopt it get the papers printed
done please man right now Mama I'm sorry
this is gonna be what's gonna be Mom I'm
sorry I'm sorry Mom now okay I'm sorry
girl